[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kevin thanks for joining us how you
feeling
i'm doing good a little allergies all's
good though here in austin texas all
right handicap this for me let's start
with the national league west why are
the giants the best team in the west and
maybe the best team in baseball
yeah i'm gonna tell you it's shocking to
start the season and think yeah they're
gonna have 105 wins here at the start of
october but they do all of the little
things
right to win a baseball game
so
whatever that is it's kind of like the
raise we've watched the race since joe
mann was there winning 90 plus games you
could name nine guys that team if not
five besides their starting rotation in
evan longoria back then was david price
and james shields now you look at the
giants it's a lot of the same type stuff
you could say crawford's having a career
year and yes he is probably the most
underrated shortstop out there and it's
been that way but they just play
baseball so whatever this new generation
is with all the matchups and all the
stuff farhad and gabe capper work well
together they believe in their theories
they believe in their stuff and they're
winning baseball games
yeah but here are the dodgers with 103
and they're probably going to have a
showdown with the cardinals next week
now i i know we say this uh you know we
see the results are like they're going
to win 104 games 105 games and they're
they could be out after one game
why don't we have reset you know seating
where
you know these we just go with victories
like that that way everybody keeps
playing the entire year at the end of
the season and then we just seed the
teams whether you did nationally that
way in the american league or did it you
know combined them what do you think
about uh that that possibility
you know what that's a great that's a
great idea and you know you because you
do look at this we asked yesterday on
the show are the dodgers the best wild
card team ever and i said no because
2004 red sox are dan and you knew that
answer obviously
okay so let's stop with that question
but when you look at a powerhouse
and you look at max scherzer and trey
turner what the dodgers have done since
they've acquired them i think they have
like they're like 43 and 13 or 43 and
say whatever that whatever the number is
and they've picked up a game on the
giants that's why
what you say is is
it's a great idea because it makes every
team play just like in ohtani uh you
know he's not going to pitch the last
game of the year on sunday and now
you're playing the mariners which that
could be a big deal mayors are probably
in the best situation besides the
yankees to make this situation go in the
wild card in the east but
it is it is an idea and i know they're
looking to always make the game better
maybe that does
it's just difficult to have an entire
season where you dominate
and
you're going to play one game
it's going to come down to scherzer
versus adam wainwright like is there any
other i would think baseball
searching for revenue would at least
make it a best of three i i like the one
game win or go home
but it's not i'm not the one that spent
an entire season six months getting to
this point
what makes the most what is fair in a
situation and you may like the one game
well i i know that's how important it is
to win a division because it buys you
those other games so that there there's
your
gift that you're trying to go to to the
end of the season you have to win the
division if you don't now you have a
wild card and the great thing about this
danny
while wildcard teams win the world
series also it's the team that gets hot
i mean who says that the cardinals were
going to be in the playoffs six weeks
ago i had them done that jack flaherty
goes down they're starting rotation
couldn't throw strikes they couldn't get
anybody out you're sitting here going
nolan aronado and goldsmith please take
us to the promised land and you look up
and they go and win 17 straight games
and you're like
what just happened right and now are
they the team to be in the postseason
and you wouldn't have said that six
weeks ago so it seems like every week
something changes it was the blue jays
about two weeks ago i'm like you can't
beat him you might have the cy young
vlad junior if if it wasn't the old tony
here like he's the mvp they have a nice
rotation that can match up with people
so they're dangerous but then also the
80s go in there and take two and three
like okay well you know they'll try but
it is it's a very intriguing is the word
this year because every week it changes
you flip a coin and go yeah the brewers
this week go ahead and face those three
but then they they lose the devin
williams now it's all josh hader so
every week something different but it's
gonna be a great run you bring up devon
williams the reliever for the brewers
he's out for the postseason he broke his
hand celebrating or after celebrating
how often are injuries hidden
like the true injury of how it happened
and then you could sort of make it into
a sports related injury even though it
probably wasn't a sports related injury
yeah there's there's that stuff i mean
look you know you and i are a team and
we go out have a few cocktails okay
danny slips on a step and your ankle
gets twisted the next day you're out
well let's say that was on a treadmill
so that stuff's gonna happen right it's
not that everybody needs to know you had
two jack and cokes because you're so
excited the boston red sox went out and
shocked the world that's that stuff's
there but you know i mean most of these
things you snap you do dumb things we
are human beings uh you punch walls it
doesn't make sense uh it can [ __ ] a
team
this might hurt this club he's a great
kid his change-ups devastating it's like
a trevor hoffman type change-up and then
you have that josh hayder 8-9 scene so
yeah this this is a tough loss for the
brew crew their offense is going to have
to pick them up have you seen a stupid
injury before
uh
without leaving me
without naming names like somebody yeah
no i we've never had i've never had to
deal with the stupid injury i mean we
dealt with the helicopters and kurt
schilling's ankle which was not stupid
that was just straight heroic and then
you put ketchup on it you know behind
the scenes
but besides that no i i've never really
had to deal with a
teammate punching a wall and like ah
it isn't amazing people still think that
shelling put ketchup on that song
did you see his ankle did you see that
ankle
it's such a great skit because it's
chill for one two i mean we had the
whole scene going and three why didn't
the yankees bunt not one dragon
i couldn't believe it i'm like dj's
gotta lay down the butt just to see if
he can move because he can't move with
two ankles
even when he was healthy he couldn't
move it could move
i i
i remember
you know i mean that whole scene was
just crazy when he came out of the
dugout for an off day to go pitch in the
bullpen
yeah and we all thought oh here's shill
red light chill you know milking it oh
my god heroic this is going to be
incredible
and then all of a sudden i talk to terry
francona i go is that she'll be in show
he goes
he thinks he can pitch
and i go what i said are you going to
let him he goes
i might
i go oh my god
like we were given chilling grief and
then you realize and then you see the
ankle and you realize i mean
there he might have put ketchup on that
sock but that ankle was
gnarly
it was the most unbelievable thing
because i walked in the clubhouse and i
you know back then we had camcorder so
i'm sitting over here like oh this is
amazing so my little camcorder that i
was talking smack with them it looked
like a little shark bite i said pull
that thing down and i had it there i'm
like oh my goodness gracious but it was
it was truly i mean it was great it was
chilling but like the fans and the new
york fans wasn't a bloody sock was in
the ketchup and like guys i was just
surprised we didn't get the drag bunt
period in the story
we're talking to kevin millar major
league baseball network analyst uh you
can watch kevin co-host intentional talk
plus mlb network will feature yankees
raised tonight at 7 followed by mariners
in the padres handicap this for us how's
this play out in the postseason
well first of all can we just did you
see the tatisse home run over
out of the stadium i grew up a dodger
fan i used to go to dodger stand we've
seen mark maguire jose canseco we've
seen some monster power guys step in
that batter's box i've never seen a
right hander daryl strawberry hit one i
think on top you know back in whatever
it was when he had the little franklin
the orange and blue batting gloves that
we all had to have back then it was
awesome but i remember him swinging i
think and hit one up there to the right
side i've never seen this
ever danny have you ever seen a ball hit
the top of that
i think maguire
did he yeah i think maguire did starjo
left-handed bonds maybe did it
straw i think it's happened that was the
fifth time it's happened and i think i
think mcguire whose birthday is today i
think uh mack put one out of uh dodgers
stadium
yeah that was i was watching it live i
just sat there i was like max muncie at
first base i sat down like
did that just get on top or did i hit
the bleachers and then go on top i mean
it was remarkable if you're a left
fielder though
and pitchers talk about this
don't show me up if i gave up that home
run at least back to the wall and act
like you have a shot
i remember there was one where i it
might have been bonds bonds was in left
field he had his hands on his hip
or on his knees and he didn't move
no so somebody did this one yeah he just
somebody hit a bomb he didn't even look
he didn't look over his shoulder he knew
he knew it was gone
and you guys know that sound that sound
where you go oh my god how far not if it
is you know it might be it could be it's
just like oh my god i've never seen that
it was it was truly remarkable i i just
couldn't believe it there's a breaking
ball i'm like good lord i couldn't hit a
breaking ball that far from a fungal
from second base let alone sits there
yeah but to handicap this out to answer
your question
i still believe in the dodgers i love
their depth i mean i don't care it's
hard not to believe in the daughters i
think the yankees can be a problem when
they hit home runs like they did last
night you know there's all these teams
they have all this stuff
red sox stop looking behind your
shoulder just go ahead and try to get
six hours late in the game do your thing
okay that didn't work yankees have to
hit home runs that's how they win games
you do not want to face that lineup when
they're hot because they hit three-run
home runs and i don't care how many
strikeouts they have but they get hot
and it gets scary
i do like the dodgers beating wayne
right in the cardinals if you ask me
personally
i think they'll advance i i am a
believer in the
san francisco giants i think they pitch
they pitch they play defense and they
pitch
at the end of the day the houston astros
look out for them i think mentally
they're the toughest team out there i
think everything they've had to overcome
i think everything they have to deal
with
this team just keeps plugging away i
think dusty baker does such a great job
of kind of just you know what it's us
against the world and with a smile to an
extent so if you're to ask me how cool
would it be dodgers astral
2017 world series let's go yep yep i'm
right there with you uh what should show
hey otani do
oh man
you know
it is such an intriguing think about
this for a second danny we got
renown at third base he comes back and
has and and is who he is 80 of who he
was at rice university and you got mike
trout and mvp you got ohtani who's going
to be the mvp
if they could figure out
starting pitching how to spend money or
draft in june or whatever it is because
the giants it happened quick quick
okay this team you might have had in
fourth place fifth place you might have
the rocky they had them start the year
they got 105 wins right now but i think
he stays i think they have to get smart
on the staff and i don't know why that's
so hard because that's where the games
won that's where the games won we all
have cute salaries and we got a billion
dollars in the infield with the padres
and everybody's making a bunch of money
but at the end of the day you've got to
tow it up every fifth day and the angels
got to find a way to do that yeah but if
i said to mike trout
hey
you you want to go someplace else
hey don't sign that contract you want to
go someplace you have more hits than
mike trout does in the postseason
yeah it's tough because it's the one
game that we can't take our team to the
promised land lebron can take his team
to the nba finals brady could obviously
take his team to the super bowl
baseball's not that way dan you're gonna
need somebody to step up like 17 other
guys
yeah but would you stay if you're ohtani
like what what's the reason why
i mean things have changed now so
probably you have to sit back and go
okay where's the world at now take all
that bologna out of that thing the
weather's not bad there it's a great
place to play if you're wired that way i
remember getting it you know talking to
garrett anderson a lot here at harrison
you know kenny high school i believe
great guy and you know they got four
reporters they answered to we're over
here in boston he goes how do you do it
we got 72 stories going did dan patrick
take his shirt off over there is kevin
and schilling in a fight it's big poppy
and pedro you know so you know how it is
the east coast
there's some pressure there it's it's
hot when you're doing bad and it's
you're errol smith when you're doing
great but
if you're wired blue skies
the rally monkey's going to come up
we're going to have colleen all the
angels by train
it's a great place to play beautiful
place yeah but you're not winning you
get october off
yeah but some guys would rather be rich
and buy a house for 30 million over
there on the pacific ocean that's cool
too not everybody's wired to win that's
what's funny that's why i say when you
when you go out and get free agents in
the east coast or boston or you better
be makeup wise it's not the best player
but you better have some makeup
to compete when things aren't going
great now you tell me you tell me every
player is a winner
no i know that
but but but ohtani says he wants to win
now maybe he's just saying that
who hasn't said that yeah the players
told you hey dan i just wanted to make
300 million not win and what would you
say how could they sign a guy that's not
a winner that's what happens do you
think trout
wishes that he played someplace else
where he's playing in meaningful games
i do because i know he's a jersey boy so
when you look up everybody misses his
third and fourth at bat on the east
coast the article's already written
right so they see two or three at bats
and then off you go but we're in bed
yeah i know i know which stinks uh mike
piazza hit one out of dodger stadium
did he really for a righty is he the
only other right-hander besides we're
saying mcguire
uh i got mcguire and piazza
and i think willie stargill did it twice
is that i mean it's truly i hit and
absolutely i was telling my kids last
night i had an absolute bomb in my own
world off chan hold park and i think it
free hop that back blue wall in the
bullpen it was probably 379 feet i felt
like i left the stadium where he hit
that ball last night doesn't make sense
danny i know i know it's it's
he's a talent by the way who's winning
nationally mvp
wow i mean did bryce harper make a nice
run
did he make a nice run but i mean that's
that's a tough one they're both not
going the postseason
i know oh you like tattoos
yeah yeah
yeah who do you like
probably bryce harper
yeah but i think i saw more bryce harper
than tatis i i i like to see games i
like to see what happens in a game not
just a highlight
uh
i i i give bryce harper credit because i
haven't always been on the bandwagon i
thought there was more hype there and
here's another thing when people talk
about mike trout boy's going to be one
of the great players of all time
i said he should aspire to be miguel
cabrera let's start there
because
miggy has incredible stats
he he did win
um mvp
you know 500 home runs he's gonna have
three thousand hit i mean that's
that's where mike's next step should be
not one of the great players of all time
is he going to be as good as miguel
cabrera when it's all said and done and
i know that sounds crazy for people to
think
but miguel cabrera has had an
unbelievable
underrated career in my opinion i i i
mean you could put him manny and albert
pujols in their prime give me their best
five six year span
who's the best right-handed hitter in
that in that
generation in your opinion
when they're hot
manny was unbelievable but you know
manny was artificially inflated so i
gotta factor that in um
right i gotta have artificial inflation
there um you can't comment right
uh i can't call you okay
i just love eating sour patch kids and
coke bottles gummy bears
um
but probably manny i i think manny had
those moments where you're going how did
he hit that and you you know why
he had probably the prettiest right hand
swing most lefties have free swings they
can kind of finish and do the old griffy
manny had that from the right side that
just had that where he can release that
back i'm like how did you hit that ball
440 to right center with one hand
he was pretty but if i said you could
have big poppy or manny up in the clutch
game on the line
hands down poppy i've never seen
anything like it in my life it's all for
three straight years anytime you need a
two run home run it's there any time you
need a two run base hit it was there i
mean they're both special papi i mean he
had like 500 in the world series in
2013.
i mean he didn't even get out i don't
think yeah
uh well he had to if he'd only batted
500 if he'd
get out maybe
maybe
uh great great to talk to you and uh
hopefully we'll catch up here soon again
thank you buddy you look great danny
thank you kev you too kevin milah major
league baseball network analyst